[Music]
the cow on the farm STS moo moo Mo the
goat on the farm STS n the duck on the
farm says quack quack quack the horse on
the farm says neigh neigh neigh Mo quack
neigh the Sheep on the farm says ba the
pig on the farm says oink oink oink the
hen on the farm STS clu cluck cluck the
dog on the farm says woof woof woof oink
cluck
woof the cat on the farm says meow meow
meow the turkey on the farm says gobble
Goble Goble the rooster on the farm SS
cocka dooodle Doo the donkey on the farm
sa meow gobble cocka dooodle
dooo the goose on the farm says hog hog
hog the rabbit on the farm says Thump
Thump thp the owl on the farm stays hoot
hoot hoot the Frog on the farm saay
ribbit ribbit ribit honk Thum hoot
Ribbit the bee on the farm says buzz
buzz buzz the mouse on the farm says
squeak squeak squeak the crow on the
farm
stays the Lamb on the farm STS ba ba ba
Buzz
[Music]
squeak the pent on the farm STS co co co
the bull on the farm says snort snort
snort the cat on the farm says moo moo
moo the chick on the farm says Peep Peep
Peep C snort moo
beep the donkey on the farm stays Bray
Bray Bray the llama on the farm stays h
h h the goose on the farm
saay the dove on the farm
saay
H the cat on the farm says mo mo mo the
pony on the farm says nigh neigh neigh
the Pheasant on the farm says trip CH
Tri the quail on the farm says Tri ch ch
Mo n